um
i don't know and then you guys um i'm
curious too because i was
when i was just talking with seth
hendricks and what i appreciate about
generation now is you guys truly like
every artist really is getting it out
the mud like it's not like
there's not a [ __ ] magic switch to
hit like people really think jack
harlow's a new artist but if you've been
tapped in like he's been doing his thing
with y'all for like three years
and you know and the same thing with
seti like
i think that like the work is what kind
of you know
i feel like you guys are very conscious
of the work
like and making sure like hey look it's
not as much because you
you guys could probably sign whoever you
know what i'm saying
but you guys definitely take the long
way like someone like jack harlow
who this it's not like he had a buzzing
single
and you guys grabbed him up right and
then just you know
threw some gasoline on the fire you guys
built the [ __ ] fire
from from the jump um so talk about that
like just
your guys is like talent process like
what is it you got to see an artist to
want to bring them over to generation
now
and the same thing can be said about uzi
too by the way what do you see an
artist conviction
uh inspired artists a lot of artists
come to you they're not inspired you
know what i mean they just
don't have a vision uh they just want to
rap
and i you know i personally just you
know me and john working so long we've
known it
you know we've known when we seen people
with conviction the people that used to
be
at you know 532 glen iris was like his
house that was the
the hub for all this you know how was
that that's where gangster girls
and we still just watched so many people
like we watched david banner come in the
white van and be like yo i'm not leaving
until i get against the girls
you know paul wall came down here and we
used to do houston
latex new york parties and he's like
rapping you know what i'm saying
certain people you just the eyes just
tell it all for them you know
and i think that's what happened a lot
of artists like jack came in that was
the eyes you know
even seti like a lot of the artists you
just know
you know you start feeling like oh they
gonna do whatever it takes
to get there you know what i mean yeah i
think there's they all have that in
common
like that's one thing i could say about
their instinct definitely the three of
them
you know and when it comes to
generational only but when i think about
uzi jack and seti like their passion
and their like i'm i'm gonna get there
like all three of them have have that
instinctively and like
to a thousandth degree yeah i i saw
something on twitter it's like it you
can't
want it more than your management or
your label ones
because then you're wasting everyone's
time and i feel like a lot of artists
like you'll meet
that are fire and you know
[ __ ] just doesn't work out and it's and
it's really like they're
lacking in that they're doing music
because they can not because they like
they want to you know
absolutely absolutely